[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alexis corbière député et porte parole
de la france insoumise et l'invité de
l'épreuve de vérité bonsoir bonsoir
merci beaucoup d'avoir accès mauvais
notre invitation effectivement au nom de
public sénat avec les échos radio
classique l agence france presse de
médias représentés ce soir sur ce
plateau par lucile bréau et nadège pull
jacques bonsoir mesdames merci également
à vous d'être lé alexis corbière vous
allez répondre au cours de cette
émission à trois grandes questions je
vais les énoncés mais d'avoir une
question philosophique
doit-on renoncer à la vérité la question
a été posée à l'épreuve de philo pour
les lycéens et last débat on en profite
pour saluer tous ceux qui ont passé le
bac philo aujourd'hui doit-on renoncer à
la vérité jaurès disait il faut
rechercher la vérité et la dire
politique on cherche toujours quand même
à ne pas mentir mais al'inverse le
danger la question c'est qu'est ce que
la vérité et j'ai en mémoire le débat
qu'on avait la semaine dernière au
parlement sur les fêtes news gare à
celui aussi qui veut définir la vérité
et de fait condamner celui qui ne
porterait pas une vérité officielle donc
tout ça nous amène à quand même voir que
la vérité en politique il ya des faits
mais il ya aussi après une vérité
politique qui est subjective qui est vu
que la volonté peut changer les choses
gare à ceux qui au nom de vérité
notamment économie veulent comme en irak
disqualifié souvent leurs adversaires
c'est un peu le cas souvent on dit c'est
pas raisonnable et c'est ce que nous
proposons alors que notre programme est
raisonnable mais il nécessite et vos
convictions parfois vous empêche de voir
la vérité telle qu'elle est peut-être
nommé sa femme non mais je ne sais pas
moi là ce serait prétentieux il peut
m'arriver je peux me tromper et nous
pouvons avoir des analyses fausse ceci
dit quand je me regarde je m'inquiète
mais quand je me compare je me rassure
parce que beaucoup de gens très arrogant
au nom de certaines vérités reproduire
les mêmes politiques qui joue tout le
temps se présente plus souvent avec le
tampon d'une forme de vérité
scientifique etc
vaste débat gérer quand ça mes amis
enfin je veux dire à l'époque que je
passais le bac
non mais c'est un beau sujet c'est un
beau sujet n'ont rien je mettrais ceci
dit moi j'aimerais comme ça et quand
j'étais jeune militant révolutionnaire
mais réclamant de léon trotsky qui
disait la vérité toujours
révolutionnaire et comme il faut changer
les choses faut toujours dire la vérité
faut pas mentir
les trois grandes questions de
l'émission pour vous alexis corbière ce
soir après production philosophique un
dites-vous bienvenue chez vous à tous
les migrants comme le disait
banderoles d'accueil à valence que l'on
a vu ce week-end deuxième grande
question assistons en quelque sorte à la
victoire de la révolution macron les
réformes sociales et économiques quand
vous vous prenez en c'est la révolution
citoyenne enfin un troisième question
son rejet de la gauche fait-il de jean
luc mélenchon un opposant sans avenir
voilà les questions et la première
d'entre elles vous est posée tout de
suite par nadège
[Musique]
alors monsieur corbières la crise
migratoire met l'europe sous pression au
risque même des traitements l'a vu avec
ce qui se passe avec l'italie alors
est-ce que vous aussi notre première
question est ce que vous vous dites
bienvenue chez vous à tous les migrants
comme vous pouvez le lire sur la
banderole
c'est à valence est arrivé à valence
autre jour mais je vais prendre au
moment même vous afin de tous ceux qui
m'écoutent même s'ils ont une opinion
très critique vis-à-vis de l'immigration
je ne connais pas un seul être humain
qui accepterait l'idée que 600 personnes
sur un bateau soit en danger et qu'on
allait se noyer que tout même ce que
vous évoquez notant l'épisode de
l'aquarius ce bateau d'une ong française
d'ailleurs c'est des ong c'est pas les
gouvernements en méditerranée a sauvé
des femmes et des hommes qui sur des
barques de fortune étaient en train de
se noyer les a fait monter à bord donc
c'est pour ça qu'à 600 personnes sur ce
bateau ces gens sont en danger
dedans il ya des enfants on a même
compté je crois huit ou neuf femmes
enceintes
je mets au défi quel que soit ce que
l'on vote que quelqu'un dise qu'il ne
fallait pas les sauver et assez
rapidement alors la suite non mais ça
commence bien tourné mais le débat il
est con il ya plusieurs strates dans le
débat personne ou alors c'est une brute
épaisse ne peut accepter l'idée que des
gens continuent à se noyer en
méditerranée donc il faut les sauver
donc sortons de ce baratin insupportable
de ces opération politicienne à courte
vue il faut au plus vite quand des gens
sont sur ce type de bateau leur dire
venez et de ce point de vue là la france
de mon point de vue enfin franchement ne
s'est pas honoré parce que quand
gouvernement d'extrême droite en italie
pour des raisons politiciennes parce que
j'ai lu dans la presse que le jour même
il avait accueilli un bateau de 900
personnes dans le sud de l'italie mais
le nouveau ministre leterme se salvini a
voulu faire une opération de
communication et a refusé après avoir
accepté
du moins que les autorités disaient que
le bateau pouvait venir a voulu mettre
en scène ce refus met la france par
l'intermédiaire je pense à monsieur
griveaux disant que le gouvernement
italien était cynique mais la france
c'est pas ça qu'on demande à la france
de valeur ce petit jeu on aurait dû dire
mais notamment ce bateau est passé à 7
km de bonifacio
on est même le les autorités
territoriales nouvelles de corse et
elles se sentent honorés ont dit peut
venir
mais enfin on sert ligue europe lui
qu'il vienne chez ne dois dire est que
doivent faire la france
aujourd'hui alexis corbière sachant que
d'après le premier ministre espagnol
la moitié des 630 me
rendez l'aquarius veulent demander
l'asile dans notre pays mais alors on la
rue ben on leur dit ok venait alors sur
un sujet complexe sur lequel là encore
pas de démagogie pas de solution à
courte vue c'est pas vrai nous sommes
face à un problème qui va structurer le
début du xxième siècle celui des
migrations de millions de gens qui
prennent les routes parce qu'il ya le
dérèglement climatique parce qu'elle est
traité de libre-échange dire mis à bas
des économies parce qu'il est à des
guerres parce qu'il ya au moins quatre
pays d'une région du monde qui n'existe
plus en raison de l'explosion dans ce
qu'il faut accueillir c'est l'argent et
quelques migrants qui aujourd'hui
demandent à être accueillis en faut
évidemment du droit des faux évidemment
prendre notre part là-dedans mais je
répète ce que je veux parce que peut pas
être seulement dans l'affectif avec des
formes une fois que dire tout le monde
en laissant une faute que je vous ne dit
pas vous ne dites pas une fois cueillies
mais je veux je veux c'est un sujet
sérieux
bientôt la corde en permanence de ceux
qui veulent des solutions à courte vue
jeudi il faut si nous dirigeons ce pays
et réunir autour de la table notamment
toute une série de pays importants mais
même en faire une question au niveau du
haut niveau de l'onu qui est la seule
instance internationale pour régler ça
pour reconstruire des états arrêter les
guerres ça prendra du temps mais il faut
d'abord arrêter que la situation que la
crise continue pour autant le
dérèglement climatique continue qui va
mener une augmentation de 190 % des
migrants dans la période qui vient mais
je voudrais donner des chiffres la syrie
tous les français ont bien vu quand même
puisque ce qui se passait en syrie était
grave nous avons accueilli quinze mille
syrien 0 3% des syriens qui ont fui leur
pays le liban en accueillis au million
un million c'est le chiffre que l'union
européenne dans son ensemble continent
de 500 millions de personnes accueillies
alors j'aimerais qu'ils ont comprennent
les échelles qui a le liban totalement
de que lui aussi percuté par cette
arrivée a pris sa part dans des
conditions de fortune parfois et nous
qui sommes le continent le plus riche
nous en avons quelques alors vous voulez
que les gens comprennent regarder
découvrez avec nous les résultats de
notre sondage opinionway quand on
demande aux français si le gouvernement
aurait dû accueillir l'aquarius c'est
non à 56 %
mais pour faire de la politique je
compatis à votre sujet philosophique
c'est pas non plus dire c'est parfois
affronter des opinions majoritaires qui
sont vraiment structuré par un disco
notamment ce qui me désole c'est que
quand vous avez un ministre l'intérieur
gérard collomb soi-disant ex-socialiste
clic'n discours peut franchement tu es
plutôt habitués à entendre dans la
droite la plus dure où l'extrême-droite
clé
immigrants font du benchmarking que nous
allons être victime du dossier commander
une vague migratoire merci aux
submersions mine tout ça est absurde
ce que je veux dire c'est que là encore
j'aimerais qu'on sorte mais c'est
compliqué de la passion sur ces sujets
là dire que bien évidemment la solution
n'est pas dieu on va laisser des régions
entières du monde se déstructurer et
nous la france on va accueillir tout le
monde c'est absurde
une situation d'urgence dans lequel moi
vous savez je connais des gens qui sont
très durs sur l'immigration lui même je
veux dire qu'ils votent front national
mais qui n'accepte pas l'idée que en bas
de chez eux évidemment et des gens qui
meurent en effet de voir les solutions
aux problèmes de fond d'autres solutions
au problème de fond c'est évidemment et
c'est quand même curieux que ce soit des
ong qui fasse ça mais il faudrait que
les états évite aux plus que des gens
prennent la mer et meurt ça n'est pas
acceptable
il faut accueillir ces gens évidemment
il faut qu'au niveau de l'union
européenne nous organisions mais que la
france doit pas attendre doit prendre sa
part là-dedans et en même temps d'un
point de vue diplomatique pour créer des
conditions que les gens ne quittent pas
leur pays avec jean luc mélenchon nous
avons dit tout ça c'est des exils forcés
et comment dire tout son essence cas de
l'aquarium je suis pas sûr que ce soit
des exils forcés si j'ai bien compris
non je ne sais pas j'essaie de jeu comme
vous de raisonner aussi dans le cas de
l'aquarius si j'ai bien compris la
plupart des gens des personnes les
migrants sont du maghreb et du nigeria
et du sénégal
c'est pas des pistes sont pas des
syriens se sont pas des irakiens ils
sont même pas d'ailleurs éligibles au
titre de droit d'asile sont alors oui
mais enfin je veux dire
ils ont généralement on ne prend pas
autant de risques faire des semaines de
parcours avec des situations de viol
d'ailleurs sont des témoignages à la
frontière notamment algérienne et ses cd
drame cette situation les gens ne le
font pas parce qu'ils étaient dans une
situation de confort dans leurs propres
pays
mais ce que nous avions il s'interrompt
l'essence et au départ au tout départ
peut-être faire en sorte que les pays
les mémoires demain mais c'est pas
empêché tout début que les gens puissent
vivre normalement dans le pays dans
lequel ils sont nés où ils ont leurs
attaches
après ce moment depuis longtemps plutôt
que de laisser l'italie tout seul se
débrouiller direction est d'accord on a
laissé l'italie et la grèce tout seul on
a fait ce dublin 2 3 qui est absurde qui
fait que les gens arrivent dans certains
pays et ne demande même pas d'avoir une
situation de régularisation parce que
ils doivent eux faire ça dans le pays
dans lequel il réclame il me semble
quand même que la grèce et l'italie
avait demandé l'aide de l'union
européenne
et quant à mme merkel que tout le monde
présente comme la femme qui soit disant
niveau
l'immigration a fait preuve de
générosité la plus dure et la soie
refusé l'atelier laveur largement sur
frontières doit parler on va la laisser
la situation est mis en place du 2 par
l'égoïsme qu'ils ont manifestée vu que
c'est elle qui a un certain poids sur
l'édition européenne à ce que ces
développements texan est mal compris la
manne alors c'est qui qu'a ses terres il
y avait une deuxième question un autre
sondage opinionway et la réponse indique
que les français à 61% désapprouve la
leçon donnée au gouvernement italien
leurs proches de cynisme et
d'irresponsabilité adressé par le chef
de la moi je suis assez d'accord c'est à
dire que c'est incroyable de dire au
gouvernement italien vous refusez
l'aquarius c'est pas beau alors que le
bateau est passé très près des côtes on
aurait pu lui faire économiser trois
jours en mer avait quand même des femmes
enceintes
donc dans ces cas-là on veut dire tu
baisse d'un ton monsieur vivo monsieur
mac on ne fait pas la leçon des jarres
la france ne s'est pas honoré là dedans
mais au moins ne fait pas la leçon au
niveau italien le maquereau nisme aime
bien être
c'eût été la morale il transpire l'amour
ils font la leçon à tout le monde
eux ils savent tous nous nous sommes
tous des ignorants et c'est à ce moment
ça durerait un peu comme un boomerang
dans la figure parce que les faits sont
têtus
vous avez parlé dans d'un gala merkel et
on évoque aujourd'hui la constitution
d'un axe qui être historien ça va peut
être professeur d'histoire comme j'ai du
respect pour l'histoire
peut-être que vous avez trouvé que la
formule fait frémir un axe berlin rome
vienne 1 ça peut rappeler certains
souvenirs
écoutez ce que disait sur public sénat
ce matin le commissaire européen pierre
moscovici sur la gravité de la situation
il faut pas faire comme si nous étions
dans un moment banal c'est pas une crise
européenne parmi d'autres c'est vraiment
le nationalisme qui monte partout et
donc et et donkey nouveau abordé cette
période avec la conscience quoi de la
gravité du moment gravité du moment
oui mais là on est là vous dites
aujourd'hui hélas si l'europe se porte
mal et elle est enfermée dans la doxa
libérale refusant qui est terminée une
harmonisation fiscale et sociale entre
les pays
parmi ceux qui ont incarné ça c'est
monsieur moscovici donc
c'est la main on est dans le cynisme en
politique terre des gens qui eux mêmes
ont été les plus durs qui ont fait
évoluer le mouvement socialiste vers une
adaptation total à une acceptation d'une
europe libérale bon aujourd'hui revient
à dire la catastrophe et l'allée peuple
s'abstiennent aux élections le chômage
et la misère ni vote pour les populistes
d'abord il ya d'abord concernant les
élections européennes cher michel
grossiord vous savez très bien qu elles
sont caractérisées par une abstention de
masse deuxièmement sur les questions
européennes je pense à la france quand
les peuples sont exprimés et j'ai encore
en mémoire le grand débat du 29 mai 2005
qui avait été sanctionnée par un nom à
ce traité constitutionnel
on leur a imposé par la suite un traité
qui vaut pas et enfin pour finir oui
l'extrême droite progresse parce que des
gens se disent si c'est ça s'installe au
pouvoir
mais j'entends bien elle progresse le
prend le pouvoir dans certains pays et
parce que souvent ce qui a été répété au
peuple c'est soit il ya la grange et
généreuse union européenne dont il faut
accepter qu'elle signifie la fin du
service public l'austérité et c'est une
banque centrale européenne qui impose
des politiques monétaires toujours qui
empêche toute politique de relance
économique
et si la seule solution qui apparaît aux
yeux des peuples c'est l'extrême droite
des gens se 6 de sa maison l'intérêt
d'essayer de nous de les jeter mais là
dessus avec la france est soumise avec
nos amis de podemos avec d'autres
d'essayer d'ouvrir une voie
il y reste attachée à l'international et
dans la solidarité entre les peuples
mais en refusant qu'elle soit soumise à
ses diktats on a un rendez vous très
concret demain évidemment la question
migratoire sera abordée c'est un rendez
vous entre emmanuel macron et anglais la
merkel on voit que en gala merkel est en
difficulté aussi parce qu'à un moment
donné elle a ouvert les portes
une politique plus volontariste qu'est
ce que vous attendez de cette rencontre
et ce qu'il faut suivre l'exemple
allemand dans la prolongation de ce
débat convient d'avoir nos médias pas
d'exemple allemand madame merkel a
profité dans un premier temps de près de
600 à 800 milles personnes qui étaient
les plus formés les plus éduquées et
c'est un effet d'aubaine pour le
patronat allemand mais il n'y avait
aucune volonté en vérité de la part de
l'allemagne de faire en sorte que
l'union européenne soit vraiment à la
hauteur de ce rendez vous là parce que
je le répète il faut quand même voir où
sont tous les traités de libre échange
économique la manière dont l'europe
vis-à-vis de certaines économies notant
méditerranéenne a fait exploser ces
économies là le mot qu'on peut dire
c'est que la droite allemande je veux
pas personnaliser la nam merkel a sa
part de responsabilité bon donc à partir
de là qu'on arrête de me serrer madame
merkel
celle qui met les poussées par la droite
de sa droite est-ce qu'il faut la sauver
la chancelière
sinon juste tout ça ne se situe pas
comme ça il faut une autre politique
économique en europe
c'est ça qui ne semblent plus importants
alors il faut relocaliser n'en attendait
aujourd'hui quasiment l'allemagne ne
commercent quasiment plus et bien
d'autres pays européens commerce à
l'économie il faut il faut un
protectionnisme solidaires au niveau
européen rôle localiser des économies
réindustrialiser certains notamment la
france mais pas seulement au niveau
européen pourrait empêcher qui est cette
situation absurde où nombre de sept et
en ciel sont partis hors de l'union
européenne ou que même l'europe telle
qu'elle a été construit a été basée sur
une concurrence entre certains pays je
pense aux autres pays d'europe de l'est
dont on a dit que la valeur ajoutée
c'est qu'il est intéressé mais ma
question et c'est aussi la première
partie avec 6 corbières pour l'europe
l'europe l'europe libérale
l'europe de la mondialisation
malheureuse et j'ai envie je vous dise
pas la vérité alors voilà on avait alors
ma question est moins philosophique je
vous écoute et je vais mais quel est
votre différence avec marine le pen a
pas sur la question migratoire avait
déjà la famille le pen selon les
périodes selon les moments à des
discours différents
non mais moi je pense que le vote
différents déjà beaucoup mais comme on
ira je vous savez marine le pen on peut
aussi trouver des points communs avec le
gouvernement actuel
donc c'est un petit jeu qui visent
souvent nous comparer qui me semble être
un peu malsain bizarrement non mais
c'est vrai nom fabbro sais pas ceci dit
moi je ne pense pas que ce soit en
permanence en montrant du doigt ceux qui
sont de nationalité étrangère soit des
français qui sont issus de l'immigration
qui fait partie de l'histoire de notre
pays et en divisant le peuple français
qu'on va régler les problèmes je pense
qu'au contraire nous devons voir le
peuple français dans sa réalité tel
qu'il est tel qu'il est depuis longtemps
d'ailleurs et ne pas passer de l'otan a
exacerbé des tensions à y compris
participé souvent au discours un peu et
ça a été le cas beaucoup du front
national de dire qu'en france les
chômeurs chercherait pas vraiment du
boulot que les fonctionnaires un peu
finir câble front national a fait son
beurre si je me plante l'exposition là
dessus c'est pas qu'à une force sociale
c'est pas parce que monsieur philippe ou
le temps d'une élection a été mis en
vitrine que vous allez considérer que le
front national est une force sociale
derrière monsieur philippot et est
recraché comme un noyau de cerise l'adn
du front national
j'écoutais juin de béziers du sud de la
france c'est qu'elle en dise
pour assez violents notamment contre nos
concitoyens d'origine maghrébine vous
contre les étrangers
bon moi ça n'a rien à voir mais ce que
nous proposons surtout vendre aperçu
d'accord deuxième partie de l'épreuve de
vérité et c'est lucile bréau qui va vous
poser la question
[Musique]
elle est assez simple la deuxième
question est ce qu'on n'assiste pas
finalement à la victoire de la
révolution macron quand on parle des
réformes sociales et économiques vous
vous avait prôné dans la rue la
révolution citoyenne a l'impression que
le point il est chez emmanuel macron
aujourd'hui pour reprendre une
expression si on a cherché au bout moi
je parlais d'une contre révolution
c'est-à-dire de concernant mac ont livré
un ensemble de mesures qui nous font
autres je fais votre contre-révolution
par une contre-révolution macro nien
c'est à dire que je ne vois pas en quoi
ce pays va mieux parce qu'on peut
licencier plus facilement parce qu'on
baisse les aides sociales parce qu'on
développe en perdant son discours
idéologique qui a trop d'être social que
tout ça coûte trop cher alors que le mmm
a consacré beaucoup plus d'argent a
notamment aux plus riches de ce pays ça
ce qui avait déjà la chance d'être plus
riches
il fallait urgemment supprimer l isf 3,4
milliards
on a maintenu le cic eux qui n'a aucun
effet et c'est ça par contre on n'en dit
pas un mot par contre les gens modestes
en difficulté on explique que quand même
toutes ces aides sociales c'est pas très
incitatif sous-entendu si on leur disait
un petit peu plus bouge toi feignasses
les gens trouveraient plus facilement du
boulot ça c'est idéologiquement terrible
c'est une contre révolution idéologique
avec des gens qui font avancer l'idée
finalement que ce qui est le plus beau
en france ce qui est le plus républicain
et a les outils de solidarité sont vécus
comme une forme d'assistanat de poids et
c'est non mais où est ce que vous savez
madame que par exemple la fortune
personnelle de monsieur bernard arnault
a augmenté l'année dernière de 30
milliards d'euros d'accords bien il est
passé de 40 mirent à 70 milliards c'est
du jamais vu
le 30 milliards d'euros ça représente à
totalité des aides sociales de ce pays
je pense au rsa socle aux apl et je sais
plus quel autre prime notamment handicap
d'accord d'acer que si on avait
considéré que déjà la fortune
personnelle de monsieur arnaud étant
conséquente
peut-être que je serai utile de mettre
en place des mesures pour partager c'est
juste un michel ça au détriment de la
france puisque c'est un groupe qui fait
beaucoup de profits à l'étranger dont
j'entends bien mais la question de la
répartition des richesses c'est ce que
je veux dire sinon les gens ne
comprennent plus rien reste au coeur du
débat
est il normal que il y est aussi une
répartition de richesses qui se
détériore parce que la question des
aides sociales qui est un outil de
solidarité permet que les inégalités ne
se creuse pas encore plus elle continue
à se creuser si on laisse enrichir des
gens ont conscience que c'est normal et
que on ne plaide pas
pédagogiquement auprès de la population
pour dire que
c'est utile les aides sociales parce que
moi vous qu'ils aient la chance d'avoir
un métier et c'est bien malgré tout je
ne suis pas sur une logique profiter
tétouan j'accepte pas l'idée quand ce
genre de chez moi des gens dorment
dehors ou que des gens ne tombent dans
la pauvreté parce que tout ça coûte cher
donc vous voyez c'est une contre
révolution idéologique de monsieur m'a
conquis les voir emportées pour
l'instant l'adhésion de moi je suis un
démocrate qu'est ce que vous voulez jean
luc mélenchon n'a pas été élu nous
sommes 17 au parlement et notre travail
cdd à ce qu' il y a un autre projet de
société qui soit s'entendent écologique
républicain social comme ce que j'essaie
de le porter on le porto à l'assemblée
avec des succès et des échecs à vous
d'en juger
avec aussi ce qui est des outils
démocratiques dans une société comme
l'inde le droit de manifester le comité
regrette pour éventuellement faire
évoluer des mois encore les buts
allemands oui mais voilà l excès comme
vous êtes un démocrate on vous entend
bien sûr mais ce qu'elle savait pas
curieux comme le dit le premier ministre
dans une démocratie de contester une loi
qui a été massivement voté dans les deux
chambres écouter notamment sur ce point
également ce que dit la ministre des
transports et de la bête bornes
puisqu'on parle bien sûr de la réforme
de la sncf quel sens ça de continuer à
appeler à la grève alors que la loi est
votée alors que cette grève
les usagers en sont là c'est alors que
par ailleurs les cheminots aussi perte
du pouvoir d'achat donc quel est le sens
de continuer à appeler à la grève quand
on a une loi qui est votée quel est le
sens attendez moi je suis pas dirigeant
syndical mais je soutiens ceux qui
restent mobilisés mais déjà à lens mais
le sens par l'ansés qui va se discuter
désormais le statut notamment aux dés
des cheminots c'est pas une petite
affaire
donc les des salariés les cff veulent
pas se faire faire les poches
il ya au lieu de faire entendre une
contestation un refus que là encore sur
le statut sur l'avenir de ce métier la
condition lequel les gens vont
travailler ce soit pas une logique grève
je pense que si vous savez la grève
aînés madame elle peut prendre la pose
jamais vous ne nous dites que la grève
est nécessaire je dis que si des
organisations syndicales décident de
fermer ces gens là ne joue pas
contrairement à ce que pense madame borg
ils le font pour de bonnes raisons pour
maintenir le rapport de force parce
qu'une nouvelle négociation commence
voilà et qu'il faut les respecter parce
qu'elle a dit en madame donc n'a jamais
fini au-delà de sa vie hyper du pouvoir
d'achat aux personnes jouent personne
est dans la posture faut quand même
prendre la mesure des choses que vous
avez des gens
la bande a été conseillère de jose quant
au transport dans ce gouvernement il ya
madame par lee qui lorsqu'elle
travaillait le cncf gagné 52 mille euros
par mois d'accord c'est ces gens là qui
ont une responsabilité sur les
difficultés de la sncf pas un seul des
cheminots qui montre du doigt que joris
mis en grève pour défendre les services
publics parce qu'ils ne veulent pas
qu'une mise en concurrence qui va mettre
à bas ce formidable outil qui était la
sncf
donc elle est noble cette greffe même
pollinisation monsieur corbières même
alors qu'aujourd'hui se déplacent même
aujourd'hui son faux pas si aujourd'hui
il faut pas une trêve au moment des
examens pour permettre au lycée la lutte
c'est comme ça c'est la lutte c'est
comme ça c'est ce que c'est autour d'un
lycée la lutte m'arrêter quoi arrêter
c'est très concret oui c'est très
concret la lutte c'est comme ça il ya
des effets en milieu des syndicats
disent pas tout et rien n'interdit une
rose et des questions ce que vous il ya
toujours un argument pour lequel on va
toujours vous montrer quelqu'un qui est
gêné par la neige et il est vrai que la
grève gêne elle grève
elle gêne bien sûr ceux qui ont des
difficultés pour le boulot et puis elle
a aussi des conséquences sur ceux qui
peinent et qui perdent leur sert celi
cheminots auraient pu dire rien à fiche
de toute manière la manoeuvre du
gouvernement et que nous on n'est pas
concerné c'est les suivants qui seront
sur des statuts précaires et malgré ça
parce qu'ils sont attachés à une
certaine conception du service public de
la république et du fait que l'euro
continue à garder en rail de qualité ils
se sont mobilisés
je les salue je les remercie et
franchement ils ont eu du courage de le
faire
on a peut-être dû reculer mais la sphère
n'est pas fini il ya plein de raisons
notamment des rendez vous électoraux
politique pour peut-être revenir sur
cette affaire alors là dedans
moi je souhaite pas que les bacheliers
soit gêné mais ceci dit on est en
capacité souvent de s'organiser c'est
pas simple gérer préférait d'ailleurs
qui est pas grève
mais arrêtons toutes ces petites astuces
qui vise à culpabiliser les grévistes
vous savez si un jour ce fut dans ce
pays le droit de grève progressivement
est supprimée et que ça se termine mal
par le fait que le seul droit que nous
que nous avons c'est de porter un
brassard autour du bras pour protester
ne sera pas le pays que j'aime
voilà est certes vous un jour vous serez
10 anciennes dans votre boulot et vous
protesteraient et vous mettra en grève
et le dira mais je la vois plus la télé
je radote je serais pénalisé mais vous
vous battrez à leurs bonnes raisons hors
jeu des faux pas et voir savez faut pas
être égoïste parce qu'on est tous un peu
les cheminots de quelqu'un d'autre ou du
moins moi je suis pas sur un regard qui
consiste à dire à vous faites suer
dégâts 6 bat et qui se bat pas pour eux
c'est qu'ils nous font pour bonne raison
pour rejeter les arguments donc du
gouvernement que pensez-vous de
l'estimation faite par la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur
les dégâts dans les facs à la suite du
mouvement contre parcours sup se chiffre
à 5 millions d'euros
déjà entendue puis rejoindront 5
millions d'euros c'est ce qu'elle a dit
ce matin bonbons les derniers chiffres
si elle parle de viol de tolbiac pour y
être allé avant la grève s'était pas
fameux les universités sont crème
laisser dans un sale état
non je suis écouté tout ça participe à
la communication aux ministres qui va
payer
oui non mais qu'est-ce que vous voulez
que premièrement je ne suis pas sûr que
ce soit les gens qui étaient mobilisés
et taguées sur les murs il y avait des
tags qui est qui existait déjà avant
elle dit aussi que pour l'arrivée une
minorité d'étudiants finalement et que
c'était surtout des militants
radicaliser dans les facs je partage pas
ça je pense qu'il ya eu un mouvement qui
étaient là qui progressivement aussi
peut-être a dû s'arrêter mais qui était
juste qui on le voit bien au genre avec
parcours sur pied une inégalité profonde
celle de seine saint denis c'est la
vérité qu'à l'heure actuelle beaucoup
départ en seine-saint-denis et des
jeunes n'ont pas eu de réponse alors que
dans les jeunes des milieux plus
favorisés des lycées parisiens il ya
déjà une réponse c'est profondément
inégalitaire quand vous êtes un lycéen
de lycées professionnels
je crois que le taux pour l'instant de
non réponse il est de 68% alors qu'il
est beaucoup plus bas quand il s'agit de
deux lycées de milieux plus favorisés
cette réforme ne règle rien et puis
concernant l'enseignement supérieur il
ya des besoins réels parce que la
réalité c'est que alors que notre pays
aurait tout à gagner à former notre
jeunesse les conditions d'étude
aujourd'hui son parti quand on dégrade
et il n'y a pas assez de moyens pour
accueillir toute cette jeunesse alors
que nous en avons besoin
alors qu' une astuce gouvernementales là
dedans pour dire c'est un vieux truc
franchement le nouveau monde certains il
ressemble vraiment à l'ancienne moi je
suis né en politique si je puis dire
contre nous vont de vacquières
novembre/décembre 86 étaient les mêmes
trucs à une bande de gauchistes à
l'époque c'était charles pasqua le
disait avec son accent marseillais à des
gauchistes de tous poils et de toutes
nationalités très minoritaire pour y
avait personne
oui et il avait d'ailleurs terminé ici
si je peux dire bon ça m'impressionne
pas la ministre de l'enseignement
supérieur comme ce gouvernement utilise
les du vocabulaire et plus éculés de la
droite réactionnaire les égaux des
petits bourgeois les cheminots pour
demander grève politique pour nuire au
gouvernement
bon eh oui mais ce gouvernement lui il
n'a pas l'impression de faire de la fête
de la sale besogne franchement elle est
contente de ce qu'elle fait ils sont
fiers aujourd'hui que notre enseignement
supérieur et dans
en sale état grève ou pas grève elle est
allée dans une université
mais je demande aux parents qu'elle a
été président d'accor précisément les
conditions de précarité des enseignants
des conditions d'études et ça parce
qu'il ya eu des étudiants mobilisés on
va montrer que ça va être ça le point de
l'enseignement supérieur ouais c'est pas
sérieux avec ses corbières va reparler
de la philosophie sociale du chef de
l'état exposer donc par lui même dans
cette fameuse vidéo qui a été tournée à
son bureau de l'elysée où il a donc
évoqué le pognon de dengue écouter
bernard vivier grand spécialiste des
questions sociales puis qui vous
interpelle
monsieur corbières on le sait bien les
arbres ne montent pas jusqu'au ciel
donc quand cinquante ans on multiplie
les dépenses de santé par quatre et
quand on multiplie par deux les
prestations sociales versées
on sait bien que la richesse produite ne
permet pas de monter d'additionner de
gonfler les prestations versées alors
même que les besoins grandissent il faut
donc rationaliser structure et
simplifier et rendre plus efficaces
garder comme vous semblez le dire garder
le système actuel est ce vraiment
responsable voilà c'est vraiment l'intox
à connais par coeur bon là premièrement
que les aides sociales les dépenses
sociales et augmenté c'est plutôt à
l'honneur notre pays c'est bien fait je
vois pas tout tout ça et à mesure que
les dépenses de santé et augmente et
c'est à l'honneur d'un grand pays qu'est
ce qu'il veut que les dépenses de santé
baissent qu'on se soit de moi sortons de
cette auto logis de ses cuisines qui ne
veulent rien dire ce qu'ils coûtent fort
cher pendant d'argent public je le
répète tout à l'heure je l'évoquais pour
dire les choses le rsa socle la prime
d'activité plus les apl ça représente 23
milliards chaque année le coût du cic e
et la suppression du sfc 23 milliards
aussi d'accord donc le séisme qui aa n'a
pas vraiment profité à l'économie
denjean mesures incitatives ça ne c'est
pas terrible terre que chaque année on a
subi on now consacrer beaucoup beaucoup
d'argent a pour que soit disant des
emplois soient créés ça avait commencé
sous l'ondé c'est reconduit bon tout ça
n'a produit aucun effet on supprime iss
a produit aucun effet non mais là encore
sentons que les français ne soient pas
est ce qu'être la buse et senna qui a
besoin d'un état des lieux de
l'efficacité de ce socle de cet ensemble
où vous estimé qu'aujourd'hui nous en
faire tous les états des lieux où
fonctionne le connaît par exemple c'est
ce qu'il fonctionne pas le rsa socle il
ya 40% des gens qui pour en bénéficier
le perçoit fois parce qu'ils ne
demandent pas ils sont parents par
exemple une perception automatique
s'était plus de moyens aussi de la part
de nombreux sur le terrain nous ont
faits sont faits des caravanes france a
soumis pour des caravanes des droits ou
un petit logiciel on explique aux gens
et dans les quartiers j'ai encore fait
il ya dix jours à montreuil
on dit aux gens vous avez droit ça vous
devez le demander tout ce travail là qui
est fait ce que les gens quand ils sont
dans la difficulté voudront y perdre un
peu pied savent pas à quoi ils ont droit
dont vous voyez il ya plein de choses
qui pourraient être faites
on pourrait donner des moyens à ce que
sur le terrain toute une série d' agent
aillent expliquer et aider les gens donc
il faut tout remettre à plat
mais comme
dirais-je le problème de la france en
2018 sans problème de répartition des
richesses ou une minorité de gens cap du
der est de plus en plus de richesse
vocale cas de bernard arnault comme cas
symbolique faire croire que le problème
c'est qu'en gros on adhérait trop les
gens en difficulté
franchement est non seulement faux sur
le plan économique mais moralement moi
j'ai de la morale et vous aussi vous en
avais moi c'est vraiment ça me dégoûte
j'en ai assez qu'on fasse croire ça aux
gens pourquoi il ya de plus en plus de 9
millions de gens sous le seuil de
pauvreté
il ya 6 millions de chômeurs les 6
millions de chômeurs ne sont pas au
chômage parce que les mesures sont pas
incitatif pour chercher du boulot parce
qu'il n'ya pas assez de boulot
après faut s'interroger pourquoi moi ce
qui m'a mis en colère je suis élu de
montreuil le bon temps qu'un exemple de
carrefour je peux dire deux mots parce
que je sais qu'il faut aller vite mais
carrefour est un scandale terre que
carrefour
le cic eux a fait que depuis trois ans
ils ont bénéficié de 400 millions
d'euros chaque année
dette publique dont on leur a supprimé
des cotisations il était censé créer du
boulot au bout de trois ans 1 2 milliard
ils ont perdu ils ont perçu et bien
l'arrivée 4300 peuvent être supprimées
et on trouve rien de mieux que le pdg
l'ex pdg pas se désole c'est monsieur
bompard qui quand même dont on s'accorde
à dire ça qui a quand même raté un peu
le tournant du du de e-commerce en huit
commerces etc
eh bien il s'en va avec 13 millions je
veux dire de moins appréciés de 13
millions de primes en quelque sorte
allongé en attendez attendez et 517
milles euros par mois par ordre de 517
milles euros par tête
le scandale est tel les organisations
syndicales célèbre on est quelques-uns
et même désormais le gouvernement que il
a accepté de renoncer non pas ses 13
millions
mais à trois millions qui étaient
uniquement le fait qu' ils s'engageaient
à ne pas aller travailler pour le
conclure tout ça est un scandale alors
est-ce que comprendre ce que je veux
dire c'est que la sécu entend grise ou
des profits ont été réalisés la part
versée aux actionnaires a été maintenue
le type s'en va le type qui a tout
planté et et des salariés 4300 sur le
carreau et le gouvernement inerte faut
interdire les licenciements boursiers
faut interdire cela faut refuser
moi je propose pas d'écarts de salaires
supérieures de 1 à 20 dans les
entreprises pourquoi cet homme est
autant de payer pourquoi ça n'a pas de
sens ce qu'ils produisent la richesse
c'est les caissières c'est ce qui met en
rayant c'est pas cet homme qui
manifestants a été incompétent et qui ne
mérite pas de toucher 700 fois plus mal
que les gens qui sont au plus bas
donc la tendance des richesses
sinon vous allez c'est terminé juste une
petite question sur le rsa en échange
d'un bénévolat qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
moi je veux conseil d'état dit oui oui
le conseil d'état dit oui bien sûr moi
je suis je me méfie de toutes ces
mesures qui conditionne des ya des gens
des aides sociales
il faut les aider et ne conditionnent
non pas à une activité après que y ait
dans ce pays un développement du
bénévolat du tissu associatif les gens
de il faut que ce soit volontaire à
contrepartie non pas de concret ne
jouons pas à ça ça se saurait et on a
comme souvent dans les milieux plus
modestes et les gens les plus engagés
dans des tâches de solidarité donc
j'aime pas la logique idéologique qu'il
ya derrière en gros on va t'aider mais
quand même bouchon un petit peu les gens
se bouffer mon départ il avait
officiellement c'est pour mériter en est
qu'on propose une activité qui on
travaille d'associatifs qui soient
proposées etc je suis à fond pour la
question que vous pose est celle du
conditionnement cac40 petit poucet jean
claude mailly vous avez peut-être vu
cette information qui vient d'être
embauché semble-t-il par l'ancien
monsieur social de nicolas sarkozy
raymond soubie
qu'est ce que ça vous évoque l'ancien
patron de force je préfère pascal
pavageau
non mais je vais pas dire plus moi je
connaissais monsieur mailly j'avoue que
je suis encore étonné par depuis
l'arrivée de monsieur m'apprendre le
rôle qu'il a joué à force ouvrière ça
occasionnait un grand débat je veux pas
me mêler de tout ça je préfère je me
reconnais plus dans ce qu'était marc
blondel monsieur pavageau que dans le
jean claude mailly dernière période dont
je n'ai pas bien compris alors si après
il va travailler vous me l'apprenez je
veux pas être blessants je ne sais pas
ce qu'il va y faire je trouve ça un peu
curieux tous même pour un grand
syndicaliste pryke iphone était très
attaché à l'indépendance du syndicat par
rapport aux partis politiques
si monsieur m'a dit quand il sort du
syndicat il va travailler pour un homme
qui était le conseiller politique de
sarkozy et qui d'après sion je pense
avoir continueront quelles que monsieur
soubie c'est un nom il a été conseillé
nicolas sarkozy s'était fait c'est un
homme qui met son adultes un homme de
grande intelligence est grande culture
syndicale mais quand la mairie mais qui
la met au service du politique
d'accord pour écouter dans l'appui je
connais un peu la maison force ouvrière
c'est donc quand même un peu tiqué de
voir la terre général se retrouver avec
monsieur souvim enfin
est-ce que vous irez écouter le 9
janvier devant le congrès fin janvier ne
9 juillet devant le congrès celui qui
aimait en oeuvre selon vous la
contre-révolution alors on prendra la
décision en groupe mais que les choses
soient claires moi je suis un
républicain
j'accepte pas d'idée du monarque
déresponsabiliser qui vient qui parle et
qui sembla et qui ne souffre quand même
pas du fait que quelqu'un grand monde je
rappelle que cette histoire de
communication va coûter aux
contribuables
trois cent mille à 400000 euros pour
qu'uniquement les députés comme moi même
notre nous allions à versailles nous
asseoir l'écouté peu après il s'en va je
suis pas d'accord soit on modifie nos
institutions moi je suis pour une
sixième république parlementaire est
alors éventuellement celui qui est
président tous présents la république
s'il parle devant l'assemblée ils nous
écoutent
éventuellement il nous répond mais si sa
majesté un discours à faire franchement
400000 euros sa fin de l'opération
j'en sais rien mais je veux d'abord
dénoncé le caractère bidon y compris
pseudo américain le 10 m de l'union est
logique non mais c'est possible mais
c'est pour ça dans matin on prendra la
décision demain on adore écouter région
non mais vous trouvez pas ça ne vous
choque pas ce mille idées qui vient il
s'en va il a même pas signé dans ce côté
c'est pas le roi de france
d'accord donc s'il veut parler devant la
représentation nationale
il doit accepter l'idée que nous aussi
nous sommes élus et dont au moins tout
ça dans un cadre codifiées mais il doit
revoir oui oui madonna disquette la
veille c'est pas lui qui a inventé le
roi de france mais on parle du bonheur
oui d'accord c'est la monarchie
républicaine de la vème république
poussée par nicolas sarkozy que je
combats et je n'ai pas pour habitude de
servir de caution ou de pots de fleurs
aux opérations de communication macro
nien voilà monsieur edouard philippe est
prémuni s'il peut aussi traîné devant le
l'assemblée nationale me rendais compte
quand il s'exprime on lui répond il nous
répond on est là dans quelque chose qui
prend sens et réponse au congrès
également se faisant aucune réponse
il s'emballe constitutionnellement il
peut même pas alors voilà on n'attend
pas quatre cent mille euros je le dis à
vous écouter pognon de dingue
y'a pas mieux à faire que de claquer 300
ou 400 mille euros ah si après ça vous
nous dites que vous y allez quand même
alors là
sidibé mais si j'y vais c'est pour
dénoncer l'assaut jvc pour des non mais
c'est pas mon voyage qui va coûter cher
c'est l'ensemble des fonctionnaires
allez on attendra la décision notre
groupe ainsi qu'au relais pour lui que
de toute manière dacoury cet exercice
mont à camp de rééducation cet exercice
de communication voilà c'était adresse à
la nation sur le mode américain on
arrive à la troisième partie votre
sixième république c'est simple et c'est
nadège qui va vouloir poser
[Musique]
malaise alors son rond son rejet de la
gauche fait-il de jean luc mélenchon un
opposant sans avenir comme ça c'est
l'avenir qui le dira non mais sortons de
ces noms je crois pas je pense que jean
luc mélenchon et à travers le mouvement
françaises soumises a fait émerger une
force nouvelle qui est quand même une
des singularités ou du moins des choses
à observer de cette élection
présidentielle je crois qu'il ya eu
l'émergence d'un côté de monsieur macron
qui a produit un effet de réorganisation
d'ailleurs de la droite ce que j'ai
appelé la représentation de l'oligarchie
qui encore des effets le départ de
madame calmels de la droite et de
participer à ça à ceux à cette onde de
choc macro nien qui fait que quand on
est de droite et qu'on s'entend bien
avec les élites de ce pays finalement on
est du côté de macron et pourquoi perdre
son temps avec monsieur wauquiez bon je
parle ça je parlais de mes adversaires
mais non mais non il n'a pas rejoint
on est entre nous on s'étreint terminera
aux élections municipales par un soutien
d'un public en marche à bordeaux et il
peut être même une participation d'anne
calmels aux prochaines élections auront
fait non mais je dis ça je suis
convaincu les français que les légions
mais on parle là de la journée
non non excusez moi j'ai fait une
digression pour dire que nous avons fait
et je me dis qu'il est beaucoup de
digressions et je sais et en 7 heures
départ mais je m'excuse font à l'heure
dé jeu mais nous avons bon nous avons
fait émerger une force à 19 5% près de
20 % 7 millions de voix de forces
nouvelles qui a pour ambition
effectivement de porter haut le discours
républicain écologiques sociales mais
qui il est vrai ne reprend pas la
vieille sémantique et n'a pas pour
mission de recycler toute une série de
force qui me semble-t-il on embauche dit
le mot dit le mot ouais mais aller dit
le mot il paraît que jean luc mélenchon
refuse désormais de dire le mot prononcé
pas vrai mais moi je suis un homme de
gauche c'est pas le sujet je suis de cet
éco là je suis formelle là mais je pense
que ce mot fait + écran vis-à-vis de
gens que ce qu'il fait sens c'est ça mon
problème moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est
mobiliser les gens
les mobilise ce terme non je vous dis
moi mon objectif c'est comment des
millions d'abstentionnistes des gens qui
sont un peu paumé qui sont dégoûtés
je vous leur dites bonjour je suis de
gauche je suis socialiste et jean tard
vous êtes avec françois hollande donc
ils ne comprennent plus rien d'accord et
nous allons faire émerger une force
parce que nous faisons nous sommes pas
enfermés dans ce vocabulaire droite
gauche mais plutôt un autre vocabulaire
qui était peuple oligarchie et et qu'
une autre latéralisation de la vie
politique
d'accord bon ça peut vous sembler par
moments tout ça encore à préciser mais
c'est ce qui a fait que nous avons
remportés me semble t'il ce grand succès
à l'occasion des élections
donc après vous avez des gens qui au nom
du fait qu'ils sont les débris de la
ville gauche veulent n'accepte pas
l'idée qu'une force politique nouvelle
apparaissent et passent leur temps à
dire quelle insolence mélenchon et ses
amis il nous réunit pas c'est nous quand
même les chefs de la gauche vite
mettons-nous sur la photo pour que je
suis dire je pense que ça n'a aucun
effet propulsif de dire 'voilà grandes
nouvelles têtes chef à plumes s'est
réuni avec top chef à plumes etc
les gens s'en fiche un peu par contre il
s'en fiche un peu mais on a remarqué
vous l'avez dit vous-même tout à l'heure
que quand les gens se ne veulent pas
être du côté du pouvoir ni de chez makro
ne veut pas être ma chronique il tombe
surtout dans l extrême droite ce que
vous disiez tout à l'heure pourquoi est
on pas plutôt vers vous qu'est-ce qu'il
fait une bonne stratégie
je vous ai fait pour que vous soyez
méchant comme ça les berges et 19,5 pour
cent mais c'est vous qui l'avez en
europe mais j'ai dit en france la
différence et la france oui on a
commencé cette élection présidentielle
marine le pen était annoncée à 28 ou
près de 30%
nous nous étions très bas dans les
sondages on termine à 19 5%
vous l'avez pas vu ça que contrairement
à ce qui était annoncé en france c'est
pas l'extrême droite qui est le seul
catalyseur de la colère sociale
mais c'est aussi une force généreuse
partageuse républicaine comme nous et ça
c'est à mettre à l'actif de jean luc
mélenchon est pas de se les donneurs de
leçons qui 18 je parle pas de moulins
mais des jeux qui ne lui qui lui
lançaient des cailloux du haut de leur
grande stature de parti officiel de soi
disant la gauche qui n'ont donc plus
personne
oui mais qu'est ce qui ferait que vous
seriez et parce que c'est bien de
catalyser comme vous dites est ce que
vous voulez c'est ouvrir pour faire
faire des choses pour faire pour avoir
le pouvoir il faut avoir 50 plus une
voix
débrouillez pour avoir cette maladie
quand vous n'arrivez pas notamment venez
vous dire on est bon on est bon on
arrive 3e ont été honnêtement il n'est
pas comme si vous êtes quand même
derrière et puis visiblement bisounours
s'accroche pas encore je sais pas si je
sais pas vous avez devant vous avec les
autres non mais vous avez devant vous
quelqu'un qui a encore un peu plus de
nom vous m'auriez dit que je serais
député je n'aurais pas cru et on a un
groupe de députés vous avez déjà invité
gentiment mais j'ai assez calmes un
incroyable que cette force près de 7
millions de voix un groupe parlementaire
qui parmi ceux qui bossent le plus on a
déposé des milliers d'amendements
est ce que nous faisons aussi à
l'assemblée nationale c'est une tâche
difficile
c'est à travers notre acharnement à être
présents séance à déposer des annonces
est donné brosser le profil de ce que
serait notre contre-programme moi ça
m'amuse toujours ceux qui avaient pensé
lui ont rien à proposer
on est ce qu'ils proposent en plus
notamment apprendre la loi ne pas être
d'accord avec nous mais ce qu'on essaie
de faire c'est dans une articulation
entre mobilisation sociale débat de
société que nous lançons est aussi un
sérieux à l'assemblée nationale nous
montrons que nous sommes en capacité
pour ceux qui nous font confiance de
diriger ce pays
après c'est sur le fond qu'il faut juger
mais je crois mais sur le cerveau de
sérieux à l'assemblée nationale on est
tous d'accord là dessus on a tous
remarqué les journalistes et ceux qui
s'intéressent à la vie de l'assemblée
nationale en tous les cas et vous
travaillez beaucoup sur les amendements
malheureusement n'y a pas beaucoup de
vos amendements mais je savoure sa chair
est frustrant ramé mais ça nous
commander ce que je pense et c'est ce
qu'il ya de très bien notamment grâce à
vous les médias aujourd'hui c'est que
des débats ne sont plus enfermer dans le
cadre parlementaire
mais il ya une pédagogie beaucoup de
gens moi je vais être un peu prétentieux
pardon je pense que le groupe france en
suis à réhabiliter on peut le débat
parlementaire
plus de gens s'y intéressent désormais
et ça je trouve ça du moins dans mon
réseau est ce que je veux dire c'est
qu'à travers ce que nous faisons même
une intervention à une heure du matin de
deux minutes on l'utilisons la
missionnaire orient soutient il propose
ça la loi et tout ça toute manière vous
savez les victoires politiques sont
toujours précédées de victoire
idéologique
ce à quoi il faut faire travailler
marion maréchal mais sont enfin marion
maréchal-le pen c'est alpiq des choses
qui sont du mouvement plutôt précis dont
je me réclame c'est une phrase de
gramsci mme j'adore les batailles
culturel au maréchal le pen fait partie
non courants d'extrême droite qui a
compris que la bataille culturelle est
un monde entre mais de grâce ne me
renvoyer à marion maréchal-le pen ce que
je veux dire c'est que c'est une
banalité les idées que nous avons à
combattre est montré des sondages tout à
l'heure
l'idée par exemple que la difficulté du
sujet sur l'immigration veiller en même
temps de bon et plein d'autres idées que
vous savez quand vous vous évoquez
dollars juste raison que macron darmanin
et d'autres font avancer l'idée que s'il
ya du chômage c'est parce que les
chômeurs sont un peu feignant cd
bataille idéologique qui mène moi je
dois y revient au nac alors beaucoup la
parole y compris pour s'opposer à ce
discours soit z social c'est françois
hollande à un vrai revenant finalement
politique gros succès en librairie
comment vous appréhendez ce succès ce
retour n'a pas l'impression qu'il est
retraité finalement du moins c'est un
coup dur pour olivier faure à mon avis
parce que c'est dans le vide de ce
qu'est le parti socialiste voilà les
gens se disent bon si hollande était pas
terrible mais peut-être que finalement
on pour ce qui est du ps y'a pas mieux
qui a émergé
bon après comment dirais-je vous savez
qu'un ancien président de la république
ce qui est bien d'ailleurs aille dans
des grandes surfaces signe un bouquin ça
crée un effet c'est normal les gens
voient pas tous les gens prieront la
république donc on va il est plutôt
bonhomme il est sympa il épate l'ain ils
consacrent du temps à dédicacer des
bouquins d'une revit au contact mais
j'ai compris je pense qu'après toutes
les blessures qu'il a subies
là je vais faire la main écologie la
petite semaine mais ça lui fait du bien
c'est peut-être annonçant cet homme est
responsable de tout et franchement son
bilan et politiquement terrible c'est un
échec mais il n'a même pas pu se
représenter et d'une chose fondamentale
dit ce n'est jamais la radicalité qui a
conduit la gauche au pouvoir
donc ce que vous prenez non c'est le
réformisme il dit vrai nom mais tout ça
c'est du baratin à redon je veux dire
son échec est tel que monsieur hollande
c'est une première dans l'histoire vème
république n'a même pas pu se présenter
devant les électeurs s'ils étaient allés
ses frais de campagne était même pas
remboursé d'accord donc dans un sursaut
de lucidité il s'est dit j'y vais pas la
seule chose qu'il a pu fabriquer c'est
premièrement détruire complètement son
parti politique qui aujourd'hui dans un
sale état
et deuxièmement fabriquer un monstre
politique qui s'appelle emmanuel macron
ensuite analysant la politique qui
l'amenait il avait dit je serai jugé à
l'aune du chômage d'accord du recul du
chômage d'ailleurs le cicg mettre en
place le chômage a continué d'augmenter
là je veux bien être à avoir j'arrivais
chrétienne au fond moi parce qu'après
tout c'est un bon garçon mais c'est pas
parce qu'il vend quelques bouquins
hauteur par ailleurs à peine salle jean
luc mélenchon dans plus de livres c'est
la vérité comme il a vendu 70 80 le
préfet nature s'est pas non plus marc
léri quoi bon dernière question je mens
je ne crois pas qu'il ya une envie pour
terminer pas d'envié de françois
hollande ou non un bon rythme et ensuite
de savoir qu'est ce que c'est qu'est ce
que vous avez dans la tête pour les
municipales vous même par exemple vous
allez vous présenter la non pas maman la
loi interdit le cumul des mandats les
mains beaucoup c'est une bonne chose et
tout moi je soutiendrai à travers moi
tous mes amis on soutiendra partout
autant que possible des distincts
soumise sans me sens logique des choses
liszt insoumise qui ont pour ambition de
continuer à rassembler des gens voilà on
sera présents partout il y pensera
d'abord présent aux élections
européennes par une bête cas secondes de
monsieur mélenchon cellules et passera
pas comme ça c'est pas lui l'héritier
non non non mais parce que mélenchon est
toujours là vous voulez quoi
mais moi je pense que jean luc mélenchon
il est en très bon état de marche et
c'est toujours fabuleux émetteurs de nos
idées après françois c'est un grand
talent vous savez on est en plein de
coupe du monde dans une équipe qui a des
bons joueurs et il faut qu'ils des bons
joueurs partout
françois il tente des bons joueurs mais
on est dix sept bons joueurs voilà merci
beaucoup la semaine prochaine ça va vous
faire plaisir alexis corbière notre
invité sera monsieur pascal pavageau le
secrétaire-général voilà mais force
ouvrière merci à tous bonsoir mesdames
ira très vite
[Musique]